something happened on Christmas Eve in
1914 in the trenches World War one
during the Battle of Ypres and world war
one was the most sickening of wars as
far as I can tell a world of death and
destruction and fire and pain and mud
and suffering and as the British
prepared for an attack that Christmas
Eve they heard the Germans their enemy
across the way and they heard the
Germans laughing and singing Christmas
carols and eventually the Germans called
out come on over Tommy which is slang
for a British soldier and they said we
won't fire at you and eventually the
British cautiously started to head over
and the Germans came out and started to
head over they head toward each other
and eventually they all met in no-man's
land when they got there they talked and
they laughed and they sang and they
joked and they told stories and the
legend is that they even played some
soccer and most important at that moment
they saw each other as humans as fellow
human beings
and eventually as the morning came on
they all went back to their trenches and
when they got back to their trenches
they put down their weapons they sat
there and they they yelled jokes back
and forth and they in fight and for a
couple days there was peace and the
soldiers thought to themselves what are
we even fighting for how did we end up
here and why are we killing each other
and these soldiers on both sides the
Germans and the British realized that
there supposedly monstrous enemy they
were just other men other men with
different backgrounds and different
cultures and different languages but
they realized that their enemy were just
men like them they realized that they
were all people and on the third day the
Germans were ordered from High Command
to shoot their machine guns and so the
Germans told the British what time they
were gonna shoot and they said they were
gonna shoot high so the British should
get low and take cover around that
certain time to make sure nobody got
hurt and that's what happened
the Germans shot high and no one got
hurt in another couple of days of peace
went by but then an order came from the
British headquarters
and it said that anyone found
fraternizing with the enemy would be
court-martialed and if they were not
fighting the enemy and they were found
guilty of that they would be executed
and the generals got their way they got
what they wanted and that night the war
the horrendous war on that patch of land
commenced again and the bombs and the
mortars and the fire and the bullets
they all came to extract their toll and
destroy and maim and kill these men on
both sides
and that is an awful end to a beautiful
story it takes that beautiful story and
turns it into a nightmare
but in that story there's a glimpse of
hope the hope is that we as human beings
can see other people as human beings and
then know we can and I know it's not
always easy but we need to do this on
both sides of the trenches and if you're
a protester looking at a police officer
or looking at a National Guard soldier
please take a moment to remember that
that police officer or that soldier is a
son or a father or a mother or a
daughter or a brother or a sister
remember that that soldier or that
officer is a person and if you are a
police officer or you're a soldier and
you're looking at a protester or even a
rioter please please remember the same
thing that you are looking at a person a
person like you a person with a family a
person with aspirations a person with
hope a person with pain and sadness and
joy and misery a person with hate and a
person with love
a person like you look it can be easy to
dehumanize others and when we determine
eyes we separate people from who we are
from what we are and it becomes easy to
hate them because they are different
from us well I'm telling you they are
not that different the person you are
looking at that is a person and yes
they're angry and yes they're frustrated
yes they're scared and they're tired and
they're fed up and they're aggravated
and they're full of potential and they
are deeply flawed in other words they
are a person just like you
please remember that be safe out there
[Music]
and try to take care of one another